[Music]
there will be no minimization here this
is soy the place move on it's not the
same talk but I think it has the same
flavor so so I'm going to speak about
the module of maximization and I'm going
to first because I know not all of you
know about this I'm going to define very
slowly what or sub-module of functions
what are the main problems with with
submodular functions and maybe convince
you that this is interesting to work on
and then I'm going to show you like the
sequence of several results which I
think very elegant most of them except
for the last one which is my result so
they're really elegant and all proof
skills a maximum of two slides long this
is the Palmas so I think all of you can
understand and what I want you to see is
to see the connection between these
problems also so I first will speak a
bit about classical approaches for
Maximizer modular functions mostly
combinatorial approaches and then this
is a relaxation workshop so I'll come up
with newer approaches that are based on
relaxation and do you will see the
connection this is what I want you to
see to see the connection between these
classical results and these newer
approaches and as I said I chose only
problems at all I think more elegant and
and very nice to present then to the end
I will discuss some open problems and
what are the research direction some of
the research directions in this field so
when I think about submodular functions
I always think about what is the best
dessert to add to a meal so what are
some model of function so think that you
have you already have two meals this is
a smaller meal this meal has also these
ingredients but also these dishes and
then you think what is the added value
if I add this dessert to each of the
meals right and when you think about it
this meal might have another dessert so
the answer I think should be the dessert
worth more when you add it to this meal
than to this meal and this makes sense
this is exactly what's a modular so what
is a modular you have n elements say 1 2
n these are the dishes and then it's a
function I I define it as a non-negative
function that gives each meal some value
and then this is the definition that
that I like if you take a meal a and the
Milby that contains meal a then adding
the dessert to me to the smaller one
worth more than adding it to the larger
meal ok so this is the dessert this is
the marginal contribution so this is
diminishing return kind of thing and you
can pull quite easily but this is
equivalent to more standard may be a
definition that for any two subsets f of
s plus f of T is at least f of the union
of s and T plus the intersection of s
and T so this is the definition but
remember this one that adding an element
to a smaller set is worth more
so here is a concrete example just to
see what else the model set function so
we have three elements here so these
subsets of size 0 subsets of size 1
subset of size 2 and the subset of size
3 and what do we need to check with this
is a model so for example you see that
adding banana 2 to the empty set worth 5
while adding banana to Apple was only 4
and then adding banana to Apple NFL is
worth only 3 okay so this is like
decreasing marginals okay so what do we
need more so so if you keep functions
like this like a table with all subsets
it would take a lot of large number
exponential number in the size of the
subset so what we usually assume is some
kind of Oracle and this is the most
common Oracle so you have what is known
as the value Oracle that whenever you
give a subset it will just return you
the value of of the function on this
subset and this is the only access that
you have to the actual function so we
would like to maximize or minimize the
function this is the only access that we
have what else so here is another
definition that we will use a
monotonicity so a function is monotone
if for every a and every B that contains
a the value of B is more than the value
of a so this is what I called additional
desert level health so you know it's not
completely true all the time but in some
cases it might be
so here are more concrete examples just
to have in mind
so set cover for example in set cover we
have a set of elements you want to en
and we have subset on these elements you
can think about elements as point P land
and subsets or just subsets of the
points and then F of s is just the
number of points that you cover so it's
quite easy to convince yourself that
this is a modular because if you have a
subset of subsets and you add additional
set to it it will cover less if the
subset has more sets more sets meaning
containing so this is this is the
monotone submodular function because you
will never decrease here's another
classic submodular function it's the cut
function so cut function you are given a
graph may be directed or undirected may
be with capacities or just with capacity
one and then whenever we take some nodes
this is just a number of edges with
course this cut or the total capacity
but cause this cut so this is a small
exercise to see that this is indeed a
submodular function but it's a non
monotone so for example if you take the
whole set there will be no edges so this
is an example for a non monotone
sub-module function so what do we want
to do with with such functions at least
here okay it's also there is a lot of
other motivation but I'm not going to
speak about but in combinatorics rank
function of naturally they'll go with
magenta away it's the dessert problem
right the value of every one may be
submodular in learning many other
applications but we take the abstract
submodular function here so what do we
want to do is the model of function so
we might want to minimize this but we
don't do we will not do it here and but
what we want to do here is maximizing
this term or
function so maybe the natural question
is maximized just the subs that find a
subset which maximize the value of the
function so this is the unconstraint
some module of function maximization or
just find the best meal overall you were
given dishes find the best meal this is
only interesting right in the non
monotone case because otherwise just
take everything so this is and this
generalizes for example Mark Scott or
Max directed cut generalization another
problem is the model maximization with
cardinality constraint for example so
you want to find the best meal with at
most k dishes this is the the problem
it's also interesting in the in the
monotone end in the non monotone case
and the generalized problems at max cake
average when the function is a coverage
max cut with specified size or things
like this but in general you have many
other constraints so we're in
optimization so you can think about find
with exactly K elements maybe you have
metroid' constraints may be general
packing knapsack you can think of any
problem any problem which is in the
linear case you can think about it when
this function is some modular up until
now motivation
okay so here is the first algorithm that
I want to show you and I'm going to
repeat the proof of this algorithm three
times in this talk in different settings
so if you don't understand the proof
where now you will understand the next
time and it's not the last time the last
time is more involved but this is the
just the greedy algorithm so I want to
choose at most K elements so what should
I do
I want two dishes out of to choose so I
start with an empty status is very
natural and then what is a good element
so you can think about the good element
is something but right now looks good so
this is the marginal contribution to my
current meal and then I'll just add the
one that adds the most maybe to mistake
but it looks good right now and then I
just I simply add it until I find the at
most K elements so this is already in
the 70s will prove it it is 1 minus 1
over e approximation kind of 0.63 for
maximizing monotone submodular functions
so we will see why it doesn't work on
the non monotonic case and actually this
is the best possible so this is
information theoretic so this is if you
have any algorithm that any algorithm
that will break this one minus one over
it will have to have exponential number
of Oracle accesses to to the submodular
function so so in principle if you have
for example trivially if you can access
2 to the N times you can just find the
maximum so this is the main point so
here is the analysis first time but I'm
doing the analysis so and it's very
simple three steps one is the greedy
ones that would lock in one monotonicity
so how much do I increase from si the
value of Si from si minus one so I
choose the best item that is right now
this is at least the average of choosing
any of the options
any of the optimal solution that they
don't know what they are right this is
just because I'm choosing the maximal
element and these are just a subset of K
elements or at most K elements of opt so
this is the greedy step then this is a
property that I didn't prove of
submodule ality but you can believe it
it's very simple to prove it the
marginal contribution if you add each
element separately to si minus one is at
least if you just take all of them
together and add them to the subset okay
so this is the property that we'll use
so I'm using this property and then by
monotonicity I know that the value of Si
minus one and Union opt just at least
the value of just opt and and I got this
from this point I'm just solving a bunch
of equations so if I have to change some
sides I can see what this is the gap of
my solution to opt to the value of AB
and if I so this this is the same as
taking this and this and what I see is
that this gap decreases by factor of 1
minus 1 over K each each step that I do
and then inductively this is 1 minus K 1
over K to the K and this is kind of 1
minus 1 over e and then this is the
exactly the approximation factor that I
get ok
so unfortunately or kind of fortunately
because otherwise I wouldn't be here
speaking about the model simulation grid
is not always optimal it's not really
optimal even for slightly more general
problems so so here is one more general
problem so you have a partition method
so partition method is just you have
main course you have deserts you have
soups and randomly choose one from each
so we can generalize greedy and it
performs quite good
it performs half it gives you half
approximation but this is not the best
that you can get and we will see later
that this can be improved but even worse
when when the function is non monotone
grid is really bad so so think about
this directed graph and the cut function
so in this directed graph or all these
edges worked one and and this edge was a
bit more 1 plus Epsilon
so now suppose I want to choose for
example K elements and what is the
maximal cut he'll the maximal cut is
just choosing these bottom vertices and
then your cut will be of size K but
greedy when it looks on the elements
initially it sees that if we add this
one it will increase the function by 1
well if it chooses this one it will
increase the function by 1 plus Epsilon
but the minute it chooses this element
no matter what you do you will have a
cut of size 1 plus epsilon compared to K
which is the best so in the non monotone
case grid is just very very bad ok did
you understand this ok so how can we fix
this so one way to fix this is to add
randomization which looks very weird
maybe not in this audience so here is
the random version of greedy and we will
see what this fixes the some of the
problem some of the problem so you start
with an empty set and then at each step
you look not on the best element look at
on the top K element so these are the
elements which contribute to the most
among the you look on the marginal
contribution of each of the elements
currently and you pick the the max
decade maximal elements like this and
then randomly uniformly at random you
choose one of them ok so this is a bit
weird right because
it might be that the best element was
lot more than the other elements but
still you don't choose it you choose
randomly among the other right because
you should remember this example well
this element looked quite good but
eventually turns out to be very bad so
what we could prove is that this random
greedy process is still a one minus one
over e competitive for monotone
sub-module of functions so we didn't
help this part but it gives you some
approximation also for the non monotone
one where over a approximation for the
non one upon so yes expectation yes
expectation and I will say in the last
slide but you don't need expectation
here so here is the second time I repeat
this this poof if you didn't get it last
time and the proof is the same just
adding expectation in general so what
happened so fix some event si minus one
so fixed suppose that until now I chose
some subset of of elements so now
everything is deterministic right at the
top elements or just a ver not random
variables and him over just element with
marginals so this is fixing is just
condition on this on this event and then
I ask myself what is the expected value
expected gain that I gaining this in
this round so I choose among the top K
element I could also choose among the
top the elements of opt this is the
possible choice for me and I chose the
maximal element so this is exactly more
than this average just for changing
random greedy and then everything is the
same so this is by sub-module arity at
least F of si minus 1 Union fault and
then by monotonicity this is at least F
of opt minus fr
aside minus one and that's it so so the
the rest of the proofs follows just by
unfixing si minus one so here you get an
expectation all right and and you do the
gain according to the expectation so you
have the expected gain the expected gap
between you and opt in the eye situation
is at most 1 minus 1 over K the expected
gap between opt-ins and si minus 1 and
that's it yes just a modularity just a
moon rock it like telescopic some you
just add them add them one by one
alright this is just a telescopic sum of
adding one in some order uniform at
random yes just you don't look at the
marginal contribution just with one over
K because I want these two to hold
exactly this so why choosing the maximal
element I can just choose the one of the
elements uniform no clue it might be so
this is this is not optimal so maybe
this is we don't know how to
yes yes I will in the next slide so this
is monotone I used monotonicity I'm
cheap so I didn't tell you I'm cheating
in some of the slides so whenever you
catch me cheating I will say it's on
purpose so you need to be a bit more
careful so think you do never take
something with negative marginals if
this is the never take something with
negative mountain arts and maybe you can
add dummy elements yes for the
non-monetary yes yes you can
ah no no because you are moving towards
being greedy yes agreed is just biasing
this to take the first element but for
non monotone this is this is the main
issue so what breaks with the non
mountain except for this cheating Ferrer
so this part right so so alright
adding si minus one might totally kill
the value of op so as you see in the
example right in this example if you add
this vertex it totally now optic optic
Union this is just 1 plus Epsilon
so it just kills the all the value of
opt so so is this much so this step is
not at all but still what we want is is
to claim that this is large enough and
this is well use the random greedy so so
here is the lemma I will not prove this
lemma for something
I think nicer easier and and more
elegant so you can prove it if you take
a subset random subset but each element
is taken to this subset with probability
P so think about peers
half for example then in expectation you
didn't kill a lot of value from opt so
in expectation the the value of s Union
opt is at least 1 minus p fo fault and
this is this is very general you can you
can even be element take the elements in
a correlated way or anything so if you
believe this lemma I'm saying that we
are almost done so think about an
element here what is the probability it
is chosen to the solution si okay so so
suppose we have a very good element that
is always very good still in every
iteration with probability 1 minus 1
over tell you will not choose it so
after I iterations the probability that
you are not choosing it is at least 1
minus 1 over K to the I right so so
elements do not appear in the solution
with some quite large probability and
then it means that the expected of
expectation of the value in with Si and
union of opt is at least P times F of
opt and then you plug these after unfix
if you plug this into the recursion you
don't have f of opt like before you just
have this value and then solving the in
that induction the recursion you get a 1
over e approximation so these are just
calculations yes for any set yes I
studied for up just to it it holds for
any set of course but I'm not going to
prove this although this is also like a
one slide or two slide proof I'm going
to put directly this because this is the
nice often this illustrates exactly what
why randomization I think is necessary
so I want to pull
essentially that the expected of F of si
Union opt is at least some fraction of 1
minus 1 over K to the I of F of
so how do I prove it so suppose I fix si
minus 1 again so all my my choices ok so
now all the marginals of the top value
of not random variables anymore
I want to see how this value decreases
in this iteration due to my choice of
random grid of randomly choosing one of
them and I'm saying it decreases by at
most 1 minus 1 over K what was the value
in the last iteration the rest of the
rest of this is just a simple induction
and just unfixing this de set si minus 1
ok
I do we just recursively do it this is
the whole proof so so let's go over it
slowly so suppose I have now these are
the top elements it just mi these are
the elements with random really think
whether to add them or add them randomly
to our solution so now let's look at the
expected of Si Union opt - the FSI you
know si minus 1 Union of what so this is
exactly right we add each one of them
it's probability 1 over K so this is
just adding them one by one to two opt
now by sub-module allottee we know that
adding them one by one to si minus 1
Union opt is at least like adding them
together alright so this step is due to
sub module area just add them together
but then this is non-negative so this is
exactly this and just moving things
around I just get this so what is the
the main point here so there might be
one element that decrease this value a
lot right but we know all of them
together will not decrease since it's
non-negative all of them together will
not decrease the value to more to a less
than zero
the damage we can all do together is not
not more than the value then in
expectation you can expect that randomly
we will not cause there much damage so
this is exactly why randomization is
helpful you might you don't cause opt to
decrease too much no so I didn't prove
this I didn't prove actually this lemma
I proved it just for for random greedy
so this is the four random greedy
buttons think it capture exactly what
happens here that you don't lose much
thanks to if right if opt is very small
and you value is very high you don't you
cannot gain any more at the end it will
be exactly that you have you have a
large value up to has very small value
and then you cannot you cannot gain any
more you should look at the equations
may be no it will not be clear it's not
so easy to see the the gap from here to
one over e is not straightforward it's
some calculations induction but it just
you should look at it maybe it's easier
in the next time but we will solve it
then it's a differential equation and
then maybe people here can sit in the
input it carries the number of elements
the maximal number of elements that you
can choose so I hide here that you you
shouldn't choose always a subset of size
K but I can add dummy elements
if your a lot a little golden key
elements I will you gain more in the
monitoring case you might games you can
ask this on the monotron case also right
so going from proof want to prove to you
use the fact a yes and then you went to
prove to which was the random and you
say analysis you were just picking the
best so random is three yes you use with
the max he's more than the average so in
this proof you are constantly using you
know averaging you know shouldn't you be
able to then always pick the max and you
know no but if I pick the max it will it
will kill opt right it will this this
exactly I I pointed exactly which is the
are here now if you if you pick some
random element it it will be known 1
minus K essentially it can can reduce
the value to 0 right if this is this
alright this will just one of them is
may be very very bad for you will have
one hour
[Laughter]
in fact it's a putting off F up there to
put up up up to e it's actually getting
worse as you the interations in yes but
that's optimized but if you can just
replace it by a pop-up flower e in that
a nice simple equation yes but then I
think you get worse you get yes you can
replace this by one over Y opt then you
will get I'm not sure which so just this
is out of scope of this talk but you can
think whether one domination is really
necessary here so necessarily in general
and necessary here so here it's not
necessary so so we can actually do
randomized this random greedy you lose
something in the running time maybe but
it's just a holding kind of holding the
distribution and making it small at each
step so he randomization is not really
needed but the problem with did all
these combinatorial approaches with for
many many problems this is not enough so
they fail to improve or for most
problems maybe this one you still
managed to improve but for others it was
problematic until people start
considering relaxations so what is the
relaxation so this is like this was here
I think 10 times maybe but I repeat it
so this is the linear case you have some
maximization problem on linear function
over some subsets of 0 1 to the N what
you do you relax it to some say polytop
over 0 1 to the N but what you should
notice here is the obvious fact that the
objective function if you plug in the
objective function the same integral an
integral vector you will get the same
value so we want to do the same for the
modular series
so here is the submodular function we
want to maximize it over some 0-1 region
and then relaxation here is the same to
some polytop but here we have some
choice so so we can relax it to some
kind of extend extending the the value
this is a set function only for 0 1 to
the N and we want to extend it to the 0
to the hypercube there do the continuous
case so the question here is how to
extend f beyond the integral values and
we have a choice and it turns out that
the one that works really nice for the
modular function for the maximization
version is the what is known as the
multilinear extension so what is the
multics extension we want to define a
value for any fractional value of
between 0 1 so this capital f of X that
I will call it f of X from now is just
the expected value of the original
function f when you choose randomly each
element with probability X independently
so this is the handle you can think
about just a random subset that you
choose out according to these marginals
and this is exactly what is the
probability that f of s of a subset
assists the product of X ax of e inside
s that these are were chosen and 1 minus
f of X of e on e outside of s and just
the obvious of observation that should
observe now is that if you plug in hill
integral vector X it will give you the
same value all right it will give you
the the exactly the subset so this is an
extension
so so you can prove many many properties
you want it to be concave you can move
pour many properties of this multilinear
extension so first it's not convex and
not compare concave but well are some
properties which still hold that you
expect from an extension of a submodular
function better are nice so for example
if f is monotone it's quite easy to see
that the derivative by some any X is
non-negative this is in the discrete
case it was just monotonicity but if you
add an element you are not losing
anything now second derivative
according to XE is just zero because
it's multilinear right but if you take
derivative by X I and X J then you can
prove that this is non-negative and this
is due to thermal duality and it
correspond kind of the property that if
you add ej2 to s it was more than a DJ
to a substance with union a ice for some
AI so this is kind of the decreasing
marginal property that you have you and
in general you can prove it it's not
concave but its concave and positive
directions or non-negative directions
time but what properties we are using
here so so we'll use few properties of
the multilinear extension that i will
not pull so first this is the fractional
version of the property that I already
used that if you add elements to some
fractional subset X one-by-one the
marginal contribution of this is more
than just adding all of this set to 2x
so so now this is the union here they
all is just maximize every coordinate so
taking the max over every coordinate
and I will use the property that issue
if f is monotone then adding a subset a
- to access more than f of X and finally
if you take like two minutes and and
computed the derivative because it's
it's multi linear so the derivative is
just linear you get that the derivative
of f of X from E is just a marginal
contribution of adding e to this
fraction divided by 1 minus XE simin
vertex E is not 1/4 and we will have the
assumption here that is not true that we
can actually get values of these of f of
X and the derivative of f of X freely
and and and aq8 which is not true but
there I will speak about it in the last
slide baby but now what is our approach
so the approach is just solve the
relaxation approximately and then round
the fractional solution again may be
approximately so this is the main
approach also in the linear case so one
thing I will not speak in this talk I
will not have time even so it can done
in in many ways and you can spend the
whole talk on rounding many times you
can even do it with no loss always very
small loss for example if it is the
unconstrained case what can you do just
toss everything with the probability and
you get in expectation the same so here
what I will speak is how well can we
solve the multi linear relaxation itself
this is what I will speak so I will take
a very general problem of just
approximating the multi relaxation on a
Down closed polytop so this will work
for any down closed polytope what is the
down closed-bolt up if you take some
wine P and you
decrease the Sun of its coordinate then
you are staying at B this is a down
close you can think about just
cardinality constraint just a less than
K or Metroid's or any packing so what is
known about this problem so here I will
let you start this form in it these are
algorithms that are an orbital is in
increasing order
so from zero point three to five to the
current best which I will show you of
0.385 and here you have some hardness
again this is information so if you want
to gain more you need exponential number
of value more heads so the current best
is 0.478 so there is still a gap here
now the only nice number 0 0.5 and 1
over e so what is a nice number that is
in between these so it's unclear so if
you know if any nice number you can get
I will show you mostly this result and
then I will use this result and to get
the best possible bound that that we got
recently I just removed with if the
function is monotone everything is known
so you know that you can approximate it
to 1 minus 1 over e on down plus then
this is the best the best possible even
in some explicit some modular functions
okay so here is the last greedy one and
this is the measured continuous greedy
that I will show it's very very simple
and looks you should see that it looks
very much the same as in the random
greedy case so we will start with an
empty solution it's the zero vector and
then I describe it continuously between
T equals 0 and 1 so at anytime in the
middle what you look is you try to find
the X inside your polytop that has the
highest marginal contribution so if you
fully add these this element it will be
the maximal contribution so if you think
about it in the code analytical science
these are just the K elements with
highest marginal contribution and then
you move a small step to not to this
direction but to some direction which is
panelized by 1 minus 1 ye the current
solution and we will see in a minute why
we are doing it
so just remark yes what the Al marks yes
this is yes it's 4 X X is a vector okay
yes it should be yes yes a summation yes
it should be summation so just a hill
what in any polytope we just solve some
linear optimization problem so if it's
cardinality it's really easy so we
assume that this is possible so this is
called PS solvable okay so analysis I
said the two slides maybe three to stop
so so here I remind you just what what
vector we choose and what is the step
that we take so first why it is a
feasible solution this is just because
of down closed so we know that X is in P
right because we choose it in P so we
just make a small step towards so 1
minus y ye of the XE is also inside P
because of down closed and then we take
a small step on to this direction we
walk from T equals 0 to 1 so this is
just the convex combination of points in
P so this is feasible and now
approximation so this is the last time
you see the same proof on the board so
what is how much do you get
so now it's the derivative of what you
gain this is by just chain rule right
and then I plug here the derivative
according to ye I plugged it to here so
this is just plugging then you should
recall that the derivative is just the
marginal over 1 minus ye right so this
is these are just the marginals marginal
contribution and then so when I chose X
I chose it to buy the modular so this is
the greedy step I could choose the
optimal solution and this would give me
this amount right so this is the greedy
step because I chose the best X this is
more than just adding the elements of
opt at this current time and now by
sub-module allottee this is the union of
my current solution with opt - Deker the
value in the current solution now any
day know n is then just a set of
elements i didn't state it explicitly
healed well like XE 1 XE n so this is
just the sum of all the elements now in
the monotone case analysis is is almost
the same right the derivative adjust we
know it's this this is more than fo opt
then you get a differential equation you
solve it you get 1 minus 1 over e which
is optimal in the non monotony should
walk a bit harder you can pull the
continuous version of what we had before
but the union of X and opt is just a X's
should treat it now as the probability
of choosing ly
so it helps opt like the maximal
coordinate that you choose but the
maximal coordinate that you choose is at
most 1 minus into minus T this is easy
right because what
this is easy because even if the element
is good every time all right
the derivative is at most 1 - 1 / 1 / -
why right so this is also a differential
equation then if you solve it you get
with each element the probability that
you choose it oh it's fortune is less
than 1 minus e to the minus T then you
plug this you get a differential
equation now maybe you can solve it on
the fly and then if you solve it you get
a 1 over e approximation and this is the
continuous version of exactly of random
grid ok so five minutes I will tell you
how to improve so how do you improve
over one already so here is another idea
which was around which is local search
so local search is just gradient descent
but you if you have a coordinate that
you can go to inside stay inside the
polytope but go around and then with
some cheating you can prove it if you do
this continuous local search long enough
you get a solution which is at least the
average of the union of Z with opt and
the intersection of zeal with opt so
just this alone will not give you
anything maybe because these may be very
small but let's see what we can do with
this so so assume here that you found
actually an integral vector this is not
cheating too much so you find an
integral vector if this is good compared
to opt you are done right but what
happens if it's not a good solution so
so let's see what happens if it's not a
good solution so you know this is small
compared to opt so Z does not contain a
lot of the value of fault or the
elements that have think about this as
a lot of the elements that have value in
opt this is also not very large just
intuition so it means that right these
are really bad elements that if you add
them to opt they just kill all the
perfect of opt so the conclusion here is
that if if it is not good then avoiding
the elements of opt may be a good idea
the elements of Z and not avoiding them
the opt is not a good idea
yes so this is exactly what we do so we
run continuous greedy we get an output Z
okay now if we hope that this is good
but if it's not good we run this
measured continuous greedy but initially
from zero to time some time TS that we
optimize later we just avoid raising any
element of Z so even if we look cantly
good right now maybe this is a trap for
you to decrease the value for two in
this time we just ignore these these
elements then from time T s to one we
continue as usual we just increase the
best that we can get the final up to the
output of this is X and then we output
the maximum the maximum between F of Z
and f of X this is the whole dual
algorithm up to some cheating okay this
is the Lamb of a freaking pool the the
main tio and so it looks ugly but I will
explain it in a minute so if you want
this measured continuously with values
in parameter PS you will get so so look
only on this part you will get a factor
of alpha TS times f of opt so what is
alpha
I do the function here you cannot see it
but you can see its monotone so if we
run with TS equals zero what do we
expect we just run measured greedy so
this is one over e right but if we run
TS with which equals one we
get a much better approximation this is
1-1 overview this is this function it
looks ugly ugly okay so if we run with
large of TS we get a really better
approximation in terms of f of opt but
we pay what do we pay for example we pay
something that depends on the
intersection of zero is opt so if we run
with TS equal zero we don't pay anything
better is zero
but if we increase increase TS we might
pay this factor with tier so this will
be again 1 minus 1 over e so if this is
large you pay a lot with increasing this
is so I do it with better is positive
and gamma is positive but these are a
negative and again you pay something
that is negative and decreasing as part
of the union of Z unlocked but we know
that we have something positive with
respect to Z and union of opt-ins even
in the section of vault right so we can
expect that if we take with poor ability
P this solution with probability 1 minus
P this solution which is less than the
maximal of course then you can balance
this right these these are you know
these are non-negative right and we just
need what the coefficient here will be a
non negative right so you have some
optimization problem that has P inside
and has PS inside and involves some real
functions like this but Mathematica is
solving that such questions with very
easily and then if you plug in P equals
0.23 and TS this TS you get at least
0.385 so I don't think this is the
correct algorithm but certainly I think
it has something in the direction of the
correct algorithm and this is the
current record so
so in five minutes these out like the
open problem so we search direction so
so first we want to close the gap so in
down close poly tope so this is the
current gap it's quite large actually my
guess is that both numbers are incorrect
and but the right answer should be again
a nice and elegant number if you walk on
cardinality constraint the gap is even
larger because the upper bound is just
0.49 1 but this is also a very
interesting then randomization so
randomization there is a general whether
it is needed or not but all these
multilinear relaxation algorithms I
showed you the kind of deterministic
writer just moved but we actually hide
our hi I hid the randomization so
evaluate just evaluating the multilinear
relaxation extension on certain point is
just the sampling of a lot of points and
then so any any algorithm that is based
on this multilinear relaxation is
inherently randomized so a good question
I think is can we avoid this
randomization either by randomizing the
kind of the multilinear relaxation or
doing it combinatorial combinatoric way
somehow
and finally efficiency so all these
relaxation are not very efficient so you
don't fit in in my slides but actually
to implement them you need to make very
small steps to simulate these continuity
and then in every step you need to
Center a lot of times to get all these
derivatives and all these values that
you need for the algorithm so can we
design faster
algorithms that that can walk again with
the relaxation or without the relaxation
so these are interesting questions I
think so thank you
[Applause]
yes one minus one over e yes yes before
the method yes yes so as far as I see it
multi-linear is just she should be first
replaced with randomization just
randomization and then d rundas so you
should all avoid these do it somehow in
the combinatorial way but maybe it's not
the case so all these continuous methods
are just the LP solvers kind of so I
would say that maybe you can avoid the
LP solvers but but I don't know how so I
think you might be able to do it
convener in a combinatorial way you set
it up as like an arbitrary polygon
optimization over yes yes then so in a
polytope well convex hull explicit
problem it's already done so for example
n has a paper yes
yes for general down one of Tony so what
does it mean that I have a general Waldo
yes no for non monotone for example for
the non monotone can you get this this
was like getting for the non monotone
case like 0.385 deterministic half for
for what matter is all so
deterministically only half
[Music]
yes so better than half I don't think
but I don't think even the randomization
is necessary but but it might to try to
think of improving the gap there is
specific hard instances this one though
is hard but it's not just we spoke about
it too so we don't think directed cart
captured we have an example we have an
example for like that kind of what
measure continuous grid is tight we have
some submodular function weird which
show you what that some random not
random really measured continuously you
will not do better when one ovary
so maybe but I don't think it's a
function with just
it
[Applause]